familiares de las víctimas trans presión
del puerto de beirut y también muchos
libaneses que los apoyan han venido hoy
aquí a protestar al palacio de justicia
contra la última treta política para
paralizar la investigación del puerto y
suspender al juez para quitar el juez
bitar ha intentado sin éxito llamar a
declarar altos cargos del anterior
gobierno y ex ministros que han alegado
su inmunidad parlamentaria para no tener
que acudir ante el juez uno de los
imputados es el ex ministro de interior
no hay maps know que ha puesto una
interpelación contra él fue invitar
demandándole que se ha suspendido del
caso y mientras tanto hasta que se llega
a una conclusión estará suspendida esta
investigación es por eso que han venido
hoy cientos de personas para protestar
por este bloqueo a la justicia y ahora
precisamente que el nuevo gobierno
recién formado de nayib mitaki ha
prometido
reformas para sacar al país de la
profunda crisis económica en la que se
encuentra y luchar contra la corrupción
precisamente este bloque a la justicia
demuestra que hay poco interés por parte
de las autoridades de querer hacer
cambios y sacar al país de esta profunda
crisis política que se considera una de
las mayores crisis que ha habido desde